よし、はいジャジャジャス！
HIROKI「へ？」
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと
HIROKI「はいどうもHI」
トイザらスでおもしろいものを見つけてきたので買ってきました
こちらです
フットバブルスメッシということで
なんかこう、あれがあったんですよ
ビデオみたいな、ビデオみたいなやつがあって紹介の
それでこのクソガキ…　あぁ、あ゛
子どもが
靴下にシャボン玉を、こう靴下の上にくるんですけど、シャボン玉でこうバウンドしててリフティングしてたわけですよ
HIROKI「シャボン玉で？」
シャボン玉で
やばいと思ってちょっと買っちゃったんで、これで実際に遊んでみましょう
シャボン玉って割れますからね
あれだね、靴下です、たぶん
HIROKI「靴下がマジカルなんだね」
そう、靴下がなんか多分上手いことなってて
シャボン玉をこう、跳ね返す
HIROKI「なるほど」
シャボン玉らが入ってます
上手くないすか、僕
HIROKI「上手い」
あ、来た
やっぱ、破けちゃうんすね
ンンンンー
HIROKI「うん」
ンンンンンンンンンン？
HIRPKI「え！？」
ンンンンンン？
HIROKI「ンンンンンンン」
ンンン？
HIROKI「ンンン」
ンンーンンン
HIROKI「ンンンンww」
あーれェ？えー、何で何で何で、嘘じゃん
HIROKI「行きます、行きますよ、よし」
来た来た来た
はじめ・HIROK「www」
行きます　HIROKI「はい」
こりゃ行けるっしょ、ほい！
HIROKI「ほい」
はじめ・HIROKI「わっ、えええええええ」
何で何で俺は？俺は？俺は？　HIROKI「来てる、来てる」
w、いやいやいやいやいやw、待って待って待って
俺が悪いみたいになってますよねw
HIROKI「つま先を使ってリフティングさせよう、つま先」
つま先ですね、OKっす
はじめ・HIROKI「おっ、えぇ！？」
アーーーーー！
HIROKI「つま先を内側に内側に曲げるとよりリフティングしやすくなります」
つま先で…
ちょっと待てや！　HIROKI「w」
あっ、あ、見て！見て！　HIROKI「うわぁ！」
見て！見て！見て見て！
HIROKI「めっちゃいってる！、めっちゃいってる！」
アァー！
いきますよ　HIROKI「はい」
いい線、いい線、いい線来てましたよ
HIROKI「ナイスサイズ」
嘘じゃん！ちょっと待てw
いや、いや、いや、いやw
もうプロじゃないすか
あっ、来た！来た来た来た！　HIROKI「おっ、来た来た来た」
時代来たよ！、みんな
はじめ・HIROKI「アァーーー！」
何かでもわかってきた
HIROKI「これだっていう」　優しい感じですよね
あっ、ほら来ました！HIROKI「えっ、上手い！」　来ました！
HIROKI「上手い、上手い、上手い、上手い！」
えっ、あぁ！　HIROKI「ああああ」
えっ、待って！
HIROKI「すごいすごいすごい、やばい、やばい、やばい」
パス　　はじめ・HIROKI「アァーーーーー！」
HIROKI「おー、いっし！しゃあ！ww」
はじめ・HIROKI「アァ…」